tenues depuis huit mois quelles sont les
nouvelles les nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement elles sont coupés de
tout il n'est pas dans un hôtel
capturé avec un téléphone et il peut
nous donner des nouvelles non à votre
avis quelles sont ses conditions de
détention aujourd'hui c'est sûr elles
sont très difficiles parce que les
anciens otages ont que nous le racontait
il à des conditions de vie qui sont très
rudimentaires et très dur j'espère
vraiment de tout mon coeur qui qui
ressemble notre énergie de moi j'essaye
de faire de mon mieux bien sûr tout
simplement pour qu'ils m'entendent parce
que c'est ça mon travail c'est la france
et le mali où la france ou le mali qui
vont libérer olivier g pas ce pouvoir de
libérer mais par contre j'ai le devoir
de mobilisation je ne l'abandonnerai pas
je ne laisserai pas
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 13 janvier
l'exécutif qui a reçu ce soir les
syndicats de l'éducation nationale après
une journée de mobilisation inédite jean
michel blanquer doit s'exprimer dans les
prochaines minutes le ministre de
l'éducation nationale pointé du doigt en
raison du protocole sanitaire à l'école
trois quarts des enseignants étaient en
grève aujourd'hui selon le premier
syndicat du primaire 38 % de grévistes
selon le ministère de l'éducation
au delà de cette bataille des chiffres
une question se pose ce soir l'école le
grand krach âge à qui la faute le débat
est ouvert et on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
berthet france
comme tous les jeudis nous avons rendez
vous avec elle l'économie au coeur de la
chronique ce soir de jacques sapir une
question et si la prochaine crise
financière venait de chine en cause des
craintes de la chute de l'empiré
immobilier evergrande ce promoteur en
défaut de paiement croule sous une
montagne de dettes après avoir vu
beaucoup trop grand alors l'immobilier
chinois peut-il entraîner une nouvelle
crise comparable à celle des subprimes
on est en train d'y voir plus clair en
deuxième partie de cette émission
au sommaire à 21h les présidentielles
2022 anne hidalgo annonce aujourd'hui
qu'elle ira évidemment au bout après
l'échec de son idée de primaires à
gauche et malgré des sondages toujours
aussi inquiétant pour l pourtant la
primaire populaire aura bien lieu pour
tenter de réunir la gauche 20 janvier
sans le candidat écolo yannick jadot
qu'il n'y participera pas tout comme le
candidat de la france insoumise jean luc
mélenchon et du parti communiste
fabien roussel alors à moins de trois
mois du scrutin tous les voyants sont au
rouge alors la gauche qu'est ce qui
cloche c'est du chacun pour soi on
attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme
les enseignants dans la rue donc pour
dire stop à la valse absurde des
protocoles qu'ovide mobilisation
nationale à l'appel de l'ensemble des
syndicats du secteur fait plus rare les
inspecteurs de l'éducation nationale et
les chefs d'établissement se sont
associés au mouvement aujourd'hui un
ras-le-bol profond face à une pagaille
sanitaire
improbable on retrouve notre reporter
questions techniques qui a suivi le
cortège parisien bonsoir katia est ce
qu'on peut parler d'une mobilisation
réussie aujourd'hui
oui en effet parce que à paris lé
chiffre donné par le ministère de
l'intérieur sont de 8200 personnes il y
en avait bien plus à l'oeil nu
dirons-nous et dans toute la france
soixante dix sept mille cinq cents mais
l'affluence était considérable pour quoi
et bien parce qu'il y avait non
seulement les profs autres personnels de
l'éducation nationale les a aidés par
exemple mais il y avait également les
inspecteurs les directeurs d'écoles
ainsi que les parents les parents
d'élèves qui se sont joints au cortège
avec les enfants alors il faut dire que
jusqu'ici tout le monde s'était plié aux
consignes sanitaires ou protocoles les
professeurs n'avaient pas organisé de
manifestation
aujourd'hui la coupe est pleine de quoi
se sont plaints les manifestants et bien
des protocoles qui change
les trois en dix jours par exemple avec
des consignes contradictoires et des
annonces pour les consignes qui sont
faites par x la veille pour le lendemain
et par voie de presse il déplore
également le manque de moyens assez
criant par exemple pas de masques ffp2
pas de capteur de co2 à part dans les
salles de cantine et puis pas de
campagne de tests systématiques ce sont
les parents qui doivent se charger de
faire tester les enfants autre souci de
taille le problème des remplaçants et
bien quand un prof est malade il n'y a
personne pour venir assurer les cours je
vous propose d'écouter les manifestants
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous venons manifester parce
que nous sommes qu'à contacter tous les
jours on nous sommes obligés de venir
bosser et aussi comme le dit mon corps
mon second parent colère appelé le
ministère parce qu'on peut pas faire
grand chose on est tout le temps
sollicité légales et les enfants s'en
sent dans une tendance dans un stress
est incroyable les parents encore pire
enfin voilà donc tout le monde est
stressé par la gestion sanitaire par le
ministère de l'éducation en deux ans ça
fait quand même 2 ans que ça existe
d'abord nous avons deux ans il a rien il
est au contraire même il en a il en a
près il en a supprimé des postes donc
voilà pourquoi la situation elle et elle
est absolument aujourd'hui coupe
totalement catastrophique pour les pour
les profs de collège et lycée c'est
exactement la même chose il ya plus de
remplaçant sur le val de marne où on a
dit qu'il en faudrait 500 rien sur le
val de marne bas et le premier jour le
lundi de la rentrée il y avait 500
classes 500 enseignants non remplacés
oui alors en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que voyez cette démonstration de
force stéphanie ça y est en effet c'est
de faire clients quelque sorte le
gouvernement puisque jean castex
lui-même le premier ministre est venu à
la rescousse il est venu ici même au
ministère de l'éducation nationale 1
prendre en quelque sorte les choses en
main en tout cas c'est le message que ça
envoie et il a reçu les syndicats des
représentants
les représentants pardon de l'éducation
nationale donc son entrée en réunion
vers 18h30 évidemment les syndicats
attendent et cela avec impatience il
peut le faire entendre leurs
revendications ils voulaient des
négociations pour des avancées sur le
protocole des réponses pour les
remplaçants et donc à l'issue de cette
réunion c'est jean michel blanc car lui
même qui s'exprimera pour dire si des
décisions ont été prises et une
allocution attendue aux alentours de
20h30 katia pique-niqué en direct depuis
le parvis du ministère de l'éducation
nationale merci à vous katia et
mobilisation donc dans la capitale mais
aussi dans plusieurs villes de france
dont marseille ils étaient entre 2000 et
5000 enseignants et directeurs
d'établissements défilé dans les rues de
la ville pour exprimer leur colère
réaction au micro d'isabelle serrières
belle au quotidien et les conditions de
travail effectivement c'est le fait qu'
on est des protocoles particulièrement
difficile à appliquer
qui nécessite de l'adaptation en
permanence surtout quand on a été en
iste en ciel après quand on a été en
hybride à sion maintenant on ne se
retrouve que des élèves et que reprises
et des profs qui ont repris qui ont été
largement contaminé pendant les vacances
et il faut gérer l'absentéisme donc ça
va être
fait recours par exemple avec la moitié
des classes on se retrouve avec des
protocoles inapplicable toujours annoncé
à la presse de la veille pour le
lendemain et des textes institutionnels
qui ne suivent pas les dernières
annonces du premier ministre lundi soir
ont été traduites en textes
réglementaires d'hier soir donc ça
suffit maintenant
c'est un exemple de mépris avec lequel
on est traités les petites phrases et c
est donc il ya énormément de colère sur
métier qu'on ne peut plus exercer
correctement et d'épuisement
professionnel une semaine après la
rentrée il faut appeler les parents leur
expliquer sans cesse les changements
remettre en place avec nos équipes se
réadapter et c'est très très chronophage
un haut niveau c'est pour ça que j'ai
mis sur ma pancarte mais la directrice
épuisé parce que on tient on tient mais
on chante on t'aime plus je sais que moi
mais correct que ce soit mes collègues
qui sont par ailleurs enseignant de plus
en plus j'ai jamais entendu des gens
dire qu'il voulait autant dire qu'il
voulait démissionner qui voulaient
arrêter qui craque
alors cette grève des enseignants est ce
un signal d'alarmé inquiétant peut-on
vraiment faire porter le chapeau
gouvernement pour la crise sanitaire ou
n'est ce finalement qu'une goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase elle aurait
comme le grand krach âgées qui la faute
on attend toujours vous avez le temps à
vos réactions sur le conte télégramme
verte et france et c'est l'heure de
notre décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau maxence briquet membres de
reconquête le parti d'eric zemmour
bonsoir maxence briquet merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés vincent genvrin
orateurs régionale de valérie pécresse
merci à vous d'être avec nous et on sera
en direct tout au long de ce débat on
retrouvera tout à l'heure le témoignage
de deux enseignants qui viendront donc
nous dire comment ils ont ressenti cette
journée quels sont leurs attentes alors
on est un point de rupture un ça c'est
ce qu'a déclaré le secrétaire général du
snuipp fsu premier syndicat du primaire
aujourd'hui est ce que vincent genvrin
vous vous partagez ce diagnostic
extrêmement pessimiste un point de
rupture je partage moi je vous savez je
suis mère dans une ville de 33 mille
habitants avec de nombreux groupes
scolaires quand on discute avec les
directeurs quand on discute avec les
enseignants qu'on discute aussi avec nos
personnels les personnels communaux ce
serait pareil dans les collèges dans les
lycées on voit bien que là on a atteint
un point de rupture
11.2 de détresse on peut parler de
détresse moi je le dis aujourd'hui les
enseignants étaient considérés comme une
variable d'ajustement ils ont tout
supporter les villes avec mais on n'est
pas face aux élèves avec les personnels
communaux donc cette détresse elle n'a
pas été entendue et c'était normal
qu'aujourd'hui enseignants tout le monde
de l'éducation nationale y compris nos
personnels les parents d'élèves on voit
ce cri d'alarmé
il faut le comprendre moi j'ai une
pensée pour eux ce soir il mériterait
d'être applaudi à 20h au balcon parce
que face à des protocoles complètement
inouïe qui tombe à la dernière minute et
en plus la dernière fois pardon mais
chez vos confrères du parisien sur un
article payant à 17 heures la veille de
la rentrée c'est un scandale
effectivement parce qu'on voulait
s'enfuir parce qu'en plus ça c'est un
scandale je vais pas les mecs étaient
bien la veille on l'a tous c'est que
c'est pas les réinventer en tant que
parents le matin même à l'école comme ça
quand ça sort à 17 heures où vous êtes
directeur d'école vous le découvrez dans
la presse ce que vous faites l'effort de
vous abonner pour comprendre mais vous
n'avez toujours pas eu l'information
officielle de votre académie ça veut
dire que quand les parents d'élèves
arrivent le lendemain matin à la grille
de l'école et cuisine alors c'est
comment nouveau protocole vous êtes
obligés en tant que directeur de dire
j'en sais pas plus que vous mais pour
l'instant n'ayant pas une autre nouvelle
notification j'applique l'ancien
protocole donc entre la déclaration du
ministre et la mise en place du nouveau
protocole il ya déjà quarante huit
heures qui se passe alors quand vous
changé trois fois de protocoles en une
seule semaine vous pouvez imaginer le
crack à ce que je sache génère et puis
pour les familles pardon mais le fameux
lundi moi jamais ma fille en école
maternelle et vous aviez deux classes
fermées parce que deux enseignants
étaient et était attendu call viduka
contact vous retrouvez que des parents
d'élèves qui est prévu de déposer leurs
enfants qui doivent trouver en
catastrophe une solution tout ça et
franchement gérer en dépit du bon sens
ceci dit on était habitué puisque depuis
le début de cette crise sanitaire c'est
l'amateurisme complet mais dans un
gouvernement où le président dit à ses
ministres soyez fiers d'être des
amateurs on n'est pas surpris et
évidemment monsieur blanc car une
immense responsabilité est objectivement
c'est pas pour rien que le premier
ministre a été obligé d'aller en
plateaux télé pour essayer de corriger
le tir je serais lui je m'inquiéterais
pour l'avenir de ses fonctions ce même
ministre qui dit on ne fait pas grève
contre le virus maxence briquet vous
vous auriez un diagnostic aussi sévère
que vincent jean brun sur l'action du
gouvernement c'est vrai qu'on imagine
que ce n'était pas une situation
extrêmement facile à gérer mais sont
très compliqués à gérer mais je vais pas
revenir sur ce choix des dix chevaux
d'accord avec l'immense majorité le
gouvernement fait preuve d'un
amateurisme complet je rajouterais mois
que j'ai vraiment une pensée pour les
familles pour les pour les enfants qui
vont en classe enfin moi j'ai un petit
frère qui est qui vient de rentrer au
collège qui va en pleurant au collège le
matin parce qu'en fait vous êtes vous
êtes porté basque en même temps vous
avez des enfants qui ont des difficultés
c'est par exemple son cas à lui et vous
êtes obligés de de faire en sorte que
puissent apprendre quand même ils voient
pas les actions professeur vous avez des
rapports sociaux qui sont extrêmement
compliquées et aujourd'hui le vrai
problème des enfants ce n'est pas le cas
vis de vous allez enfants je prends un
exemple comme ça qui est statistiquement
plus tôt plutôt justes qui a plus de
1000 enfants plus de chances de mourir
autant frappé par la foudre en allant au
collège que d'attraper le comité d'en
mourir donc il faut bien comprendre la
menace que c'est les enseignants peuvent
légitimement demander des équipements de
protection qu'ils n'ont pas ils savaient
que les conditions extrêmement compliqué
vous l'avez dit ils sont prévenus la
veille au soir au lendemain d'un art
payant sur le protocole sanitaire qui va
être appliqué mais aujourd'hui le vrai
sujet c'est les urgences
pédopsychiatrique par exemple vous avez
des enfants il ya des reportages qui ont
été faits qui était absolument glaçant
ou qui disent moi j'ai envie de mourir
et c'est un enfant de 12 ans qui dit ça
il avait il voit plus ses amis elle peut
plus sortir vous avez véritablement une
génération brisé que le gouvernement est
en train de briser et ça on ne peut pas
lier ne peux pas l'accepter le ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanckaert ya une pleine responsabilité
dans toute cette histoire on va tous y
est allé poser la question à l'un des
principaux concernés un enseignant un
qui nous a rejoint en direct par skype
fabrice frattini enseignant en
mathématiques et représentant syndical
cgt au lycée gutenberg de créteil il a
évidemment manifester aujourd'hui
fabrice frattini merci d'être avec nous
une mobilisation très suivi aujourd'hui
j'imagine d'accord avec ce que vous avez
entendu sur ce plateau et un jean-michel
bancaire qui se targue quand même
d'avoir maintenu les écoles ouvertes 1
66% d'ailleurs des français selon un
sondage salue tout de même 7 cette
décision aujourd'hui vous vous lui dites
quoi aux ministres et qu'est ce que vous
en attendez parce qu'il va s'exprimer
non maintenant un quart d'heure
mais bon soir tout d'abord je ne suis
pas d'accord avec tout ce qui était dit
par se voit bientôt en tout cas oui
toute cette situation bien sûr que
jean-michel bancaire en portent
l'entière responsabilité
on peut ouvrir les écoles on nous devons
ouvrir les écoles nous et nos enfants
doivent
dans les écoles mais ceci implique c'est
le prix de l'équipement des écoles c'est
un virus qui était aéroportée la qualité
de l'air magillem été au coeur des
débats dans ce ministère jean michel
blanquer repassant temps à prendre des
centaines de millions à bercy nous
n'avons jamais pu investir dans les
écoles le seul investissement c'est de
tourner la poignée c'est un
investissement qui coûte zéro euro de
1,1 virus qui se transmet par l'air par
contre les enfants sont touchés par ce
virus très infime en notre rôle en tant
qu'adulte c'est de protéger tous nos
enfants même les plus fragiles comme si
c'était normal que les enfants fragiles
17 du coït il ya eu cinq enfants qui
sont morts dans les huit derniers jours
duco vite donc parler de sécurisation
par les dangers des masques c'est une
erreur très grave nous voyons
l'investissement n'est pas n'est pas à
la hauteur et jean-michel bancaire avec
ces protocoles qui ne tient en rien de
la réalité de l'épidémie bien sûr nous
met en danger mais le protocole c'est
pas que des contraintes des contraintes
logistiques c'est des contraintes
humaines également les les enseignants
souffrent d'anxiété bien sûr bien sûr
nous avons une responsabilité moment au
monstre à chaque fois que nous faisons
court allons-nous participé à faire
enfin faire en sorte que nos élèves se
contaminer leur rapportent le virus chez
eux les enfants de transmettre le virus
c'est une négation que olivier ferrand
et jean-michel bancaires ont fait depuis
le début depuis juin 2020 nous savons
que le virus est aéroportée ce n'est pas
du tout considérés dans les protocoles
sanitaires
nous sommes au niveau 2 toujours au
niveau 2 dans les protocoles sanitaires
y el vivero 3 et 4 qui est prévu il y à
des taux d'incidence qui sont monstres
monstres il ya 2 ou 3 % au niveau des
taux d'incidence quand est ce qu'on va
réagir quand est ce qu'on va changer
quelque chose dans les protocoles signés
on a envie de vous demander que fait-on
concrètement parce que vous nous dites
là et c'est là effectivement vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec maxence briquet sur ce
plateau vous dis oui
il ya un danger pour les enfants et
également pour leurs proches puissent
qu'ils transmettent ce virus
dans le même temps il ya ces masques qui
porte ce protocole très
contraignant que fait-on concrètement
que demander de plus on réduit les
effectifs on a beau qu'on n'embauche
massivement des des enseignants ont
réquisitionné des locaux pour faire en
sorte qu'ils aient beaucoup moins
d'élèves dans chaque classe que l'on
puisse ouvrir avec un taux de co2 qui a
contrôlé par des capteurs co2 et des
purificateurs d'air et à ce moment là le
stress sera bien moins bien moins chez
les enfants à ce moment là le taux
d'incidence et l'épidémie va se réduire
dans le pays à ce moment là des enfants
pour avoir des activités extérieures
sans masque mais tant qu'on est dans des
lieux clos et que mon compte en
considération le caractère aéroportée de
ce virus nous en sortirons jamais y aura
toujours des variants qui vont se créer
ce n'est pas la dernière vague on est
très loin d'une dernière vague tant
qu'on considère ce venir ce virus comme
commun comme il est actuellement notre
part les protocoles sanitaires vincent
genre à vous qui êtes maire également
vous avez été évidemment confrontés dans
votre commune à ces problématiques
ce que nous proposent tabriz frattini
est ce que c'est malheureusement
réalisable et réaliste pousser les murs
réduire les classes quand on sait qu'on
a du mal justement même en temps normal
à réduire ces deux choses là évidemment
dans ce qu'il dit
on peut pas faire tout ça du jour au
lendemain mais ça fait cinq ans que jean
michel blanquer remise de l'éducation
cinq ans qu'emmanuel macron à la tête de
la france et on se dit qu'il aurait pu
avoir des choses de mise en place qu'en
gouvernement peine à aider les communes
à installer des capteurs de co2 ou des
profits 14h la région ile-de-france
prisé par valérie pécresse n'a pas
hésité en quelques semaines à lancer des
dispositifs pour aider les villes à
cofinancer c'est absolument l'objectif
c'est de se dire comment on est le plus
réactif possible la voyez les régions
arrivent à le faire le gouvernement est
incapable fabrice fatin ya derrière je
vois
c'est en train d'arriver le disent
qu'ils sont prêts voilà c'est pas arrivé
et que les communes qui veulent
bénéficier de ce type de dispositif ont
une aide financière de la région comme
quoi c'était possible mais effectivement
c'est très compliqué c'est long à venir
mais il faut imaginer la la détresse du
monde enseignant des enfants mais cette
détresse elle est compliquée les
compliqué pour tout le monde le vide a
touché tout le monde à la fois du
gouvernement si alco vide mais en
revanche après ce nombre important de
vagues et ça a été dit c'est pas la
dernière on aurait pu imaginer qu'un
certain nombre de mesures auraient été
prises et surtout qu'on ait une
visibilité nos enfants ils sont capables
d'entendre beaucoup de choses si on
prend le temps de leur expliquer qu'en
faut changer trois fois de protocole
dans une semaine c'est pas possible et
je reviens sur la question pousser les
murs pour les classes même si c'est
hyper compliqué c'est encore demander un
effort aux enseignants on aurait pu
effectivement aller un peu plus loin le
gros problème qu'on a nous c'est les
cantines et ce avec la cantine c'est le
pire moment parce que c'est le moment on
enlève les masques pour manger souvent
sont des salles qui sont trop petit et
on en est à faire trois parfois même
quatre services et donc vous êtes des
enfants qui mangent à 11h15 et les
derniers qui mangent à 14 heures c'est
satisfaisant pour personne ce qui est
certain c'est que il faut qu'on se
prépare la suite on nous avait expliqué
qu' on avait pris pris les toutes les
leçons à prendre du premier confinement
et que notamment sur tout ce qui était
un outil informatique on allait
faciliter les classes à distance je
parle pas des maternelles et
élémentaires là forcément mais dès le
collège des lycées on aurait pu aller
beaucoup plus loin là aussi on attend
toujours et encore le gouvernement c'est
frustrant ça mais naturellement les gens
en colère et puis ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont peur beaucoup de gens qui
arrêtent qui craquent soit des pressions
soient d'arrêt maladie parce qu'ils ont
peur pour leur santé dont ils n'ont
toujours pas de masques ffp2 et de fait
la ou déjà c'était compliqué on a de
plus en plus de profs absents rajoutez à
ça la violence qui existait déjà dans
beaucoup beaucoup d'établissements en
france je vous rappelle quand même qu'on
a la pire note de l' ocde la pire note
en matière de violence de condition de
faire classe et ça aussi c'est pas
tolérable effectivement on va avoir une
réaction télégramme dans ce sens
puisqu'on a posé la question le grand
krach âge à qui la faute voici certaines
réactions patricia qui nous dit je suis
enseignante depuis 25 ans et je ne peux
que confirmer que l'ambiance générale
que ce soit en classe avec les parents
la hiérarchie se dégrade de jour en jour
on va aller justement posé la question
également un oui elle est le pas de
vagues jean michel blanquer égal pas de
vagues à chaque fois qu'il y avait un
problème dans un tel établissement il y
avait les consignes de dire je ne brigue
pas un dit rien et ça aussi on le paye
aujourd'hui la crise sanitaire est un
révélateur de la crise structurelle de
l'éducation nationale je pourrais vous
en donner énormément d'exemple un que
sur ma commune mais on a un état de
déliquescence de l'éducation nationale
parce qu'on a retiré beaucoup d'autorité
aux professeurs et aux directeurs
d'école justement au titre de ce pas de
vagues cette pas trop de bruit non on va
pas exclure telle élèves non on va pas
et ça c'est très très pénibles changer
les idées après on est allé voir nicolas
glières essentiel de rappeler qu'il ya
d'un côté la détresse des enfants à
naître est enseignant aujourd'hui à
l'aune de la crise sanitaire qui est
dramatique mais que comme vous l'avez
dit la crise sanitaire n'est qu'un
révélateur de problèmes beaucoup plus
profond il est temps de passer à autre
chose pour la crise sanitaire et de voir
que sur un problème structurel de
l'école éric zemmour on a parlé sa
stratégie pour sortir de la crise
sanitaire et l'a répété plusieurs fois
et j'allais en parlait justement vu vous
couper l'herbe sous le pied vous avez
vous êtes sauvés jeunes vous avez vous
avez la semelle et vous verrez vous
allez voir
vous avez la stratégie vaccinale pour
les personnes âgées pour qu'on sorte de
cette épidémie vous avez le fait
d'utiliser des traitements qu'ils sont
un outil extrêmement efficace pour
lutter contre la pandémie est derrière
au niveau de la santé faire en sorte
qu'on remette de l'argent de l'hôpital
fait on se retrouvait de l'argent de la
recherche c'est pour sortir de
l'épidémie et de l'autre vous parliez de
la blouse je pense que c'est un
excellent sujet si vous voulez qu'on en
débatte aussi pour rappeler que c'est le
professeur qui est au centre du projet
éducatif et non pas l'élève
pardonnez-moi mais la blonde
en l'espèce c'est ce que vous dégraisser
le mammouth pour reprendre une
expression d'un ancien ministre
l'éducation en 1997 socialistes
d'ailleurs déjà il ya 25 ans voulait
réduire est ce que vous êtes dans ce
sens où on rajoute t moyens on augmente
les professeurs ont réduit les classes
comme le proposait et on va vous donner
la parole comme je vois que nicholas
garrett la blouse parce que si c'était
une proposition via nano décomposition
de la suppression du collège unique est
une proposition le préfet du collège
unique oui c'est aussi du collège unique
silence jamais vous mettez
on va dire dans l'objectif de
d'occasionnels le fait que ce soit non
pas l'éducation qui est un projet
parental d'éducation mais l'instruction
publique où vous remettez l'accent sur
les fondamentaux sur les français sur
les maths de re donner des cours de
français en enlevant une partie des
langues étrangères dans les programmes
de primaires tout ça sont des mesures
qui sont extrêmement concrètes pour
améliorer la vie des enseignants et
l'éducation qu'on donne aux élèves au
sein de l'éducation publique française
nicolas glières enseignants et membres d
destine aux joues rouges un merci d'être
avec nous également quand vous entendez
ces diverses propositions ça vous
inspire quoi
aujourd'hui vous êtes un professeur en
colère ou tout simplement résigné
résignez jamais en colère clairement
monsieur blanc qu'un énorme
responsabilité dans la situation de
l'école aujourd'hui il a détruit le bac
en en faisant un bac locale il a détruit
10 et en en faisant un lycée à 15
vitesse mais il faut rappeler quand même
nous le rappelle sans arrêt chez les
stylos rouges que nadja de l'eau
belkacem a déjà détruit de la même
manière les cols en gros cela fait
trente ans que tous les gouvernements
successifs ont détruit l'école comme
l'hôpital a été détruit on détruit les
services publics dans ce pays nous
aujourd'hui on est en colère parce que
rien n'a été fait par rapport à la
situation sanitaire depuis deux ans on
demande chez les stylos rouges
régulièrement à mettre en place et de
mes groupes pendant les vagues pendant
les pires périodes comme le représentant
de mme pécresse en parlait d'ailleurs
l'idée de faire du distanti elle un jour
sur deux par exemple tout le monde fait
un effort et les parents et les profs et
les élèves les élèves
voilà on garder
travail mais comment fait on quand on
travaille mais nous travaillons aussi et
on a de nombreux collègues qui sont
parents aussi comment font-ils il
s'arrange ils font comme ils peuvent
déjà les gens télétravail peuvent garder
un jour sur de leurs enfants la maison
ceux qui ne peuvent pas c'est autre
chose on trouve des solutions pareil
nous ça fait un an et demi qu'on avait
proposé que des communes utilisent les
salles par exemple vide nous
n'utiliserons pleine période de pandémie
pour que les élèves soient repliés
surveillé par du personnel par exemple
de mairie pendant pour l'heure fait pour
à distance
rien n'a été pris en compte monsieur de
longueur n'a jamais rien écouté et
j'aimerais aussi rajouter que monsieur
blanquart a bon dos c'est bien entendu
deux sont fait sa marotte son obsession
de ne jamais nous écoutent et de ne pas
nous augmenter de nous mépriser mais
c'est de monsieur macron qui décide en
dernier lieu et c'est bien monsieur
mccaw qui a décidé de suivre son
ministre lui-même coachée par même mâcon
qui n'a aucune légitimité
constitutionnelle
donc nous nous aimerions vraiment que
monsieur blanc caire soient renvoyés
qu'on parle pas de démission veut qu'ils
soient renvoyés et on n'aimerait pas
qu'un clown soient mis à la place mais
que quelqu'un qui nous écoutent soigne à
la place quelqu'un qui avec lyon pour
engager des discussions au niveau de nos
rémunérations sont scandaleuses on doit
nous augmenter d'au moins 40% pour
rattraper ce qui est perdu depuis 83
c'est un calcul que tous les partis
politiques toutes les personnes avec qui
on a plus parlé y compris les gens du
ministère de l'éducation nationale
monsieur guerrero et autres ces chiffres
il était d'accord avec eux donc il ya un
moment où il faut nous respecter nous
payer nous protéger du virus otg les
enfants il faut que tout le monde fasse
un effort dans cette pandémie les deux
me groupe était une solution était
possible
il ya des solutions possibles nous a
jamais entendu il n'y a aucun
pragmatisme du côté de la rue de
grenelle on a affaire à des amateurs et
des menteurs concrètement alors on va
voir ses chiffres de l'éducation
nationale en 2021 effectivement pas
brillant 1400 enseignante
démissionner au cours de l'année un
chiffre qui aurait triplé en dix ans
payer 20% moins que leurs collègues
européens
90% enfin des enseignants qui évoque une
charge de travail qui augmente tous les
ans et enfin 31% qui envisagerait de
changer de métier vincent jean brun si
valérie pécresse arrive aux affaires
qu'est ce qu'elle va changer
concrètement
pour faire évoluer les choses dans le
bon sens parce que c'est vrai qu'on a vu
nos deux amis l'ont dit enseignants et
gouvernements successifs n'ont rien fait
pour améliorer la situation
on pourra évidemment en débattrait
refaire le bilan de chaque quinquennat
mais la vérité c'est que la première
chose qui a été dit là et qu'il faut
vraiment entendre c'est on veut être
écouté
quel que soit le président la présidente
de la république demain elle n'aura pas
de baguette magique mais le respect dû à
un véritable dialogue avec les
enseignants qui sont les hussards noirs
de la république sans eux on ne forme
plus de citoyens dans notre pays donc on
a éminemment besoin d'eux on ne peut pas
accepter et c'est vrai le parallèle avec
l'hôpital est très juste on doit avoir
pour protéger les français pour éduquer
les français on doit avoir des gens qui
soient motivés qu'ils soient heureux et
épanoui et ça passe par un meilleur
cadre de travail et certainement par des
rémunérations qui soit juste je prends
ma part aujourd'hui d'engagement
fonctionnaires sera pas aujourd'hui
je ne prendrai
le concret il est bien plus concret que
le vôtre excusez moi mais je vous ai
cité des propositions mais en
l'occurrence que vous avez cités la
blouse on est là c'était le jeu tourne
vers les gérer deux processeurs qui sont
là on va leur demander s'ils sont
impatients du retour de la blouse alors
soyons sérieux deux minutes il ya
vraiment une question fondamentale sur
l' écoute valérie pécresse elle a pu
l'expérimenter à l'échelle des lycées
franciliens et je peux vous assurer que
le dialogue a été de qualité et on
redresse la barre même si encore
beaucoup à faire sur des sujets aussi
importants demain il faut écouter et
crée les perspectives le sujet il est là
on peut pas être dans une tour d'ivoire
comme c'est le cas de monsieur macron
monsieur blanc caire on doit co
construire avec les personnels de
l'éducation moi moi j'ai des amis qui
sont professeurs autour de moi ils me
disent le salaire est évidemment un
point majeur c'est un point majeur mais
c'est pas le seul
veut être respecté on veut sortir du pas
de vagues on veut des outils de travail
de qualité on veut faire en sorte de
pouvoir faire vraiment le métier qu'on a
choisi à savoir transmettre et instruire
et pas faire la police en cours il ya
des établissements aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus faire cours sereinement dans
la classe parce que le calme minimum ne
s'y prêtent pas et c'était vrai avant la
crise sanitaire et malheureusement ce
sera vrai après si on en sortait donc
c'est tout ça qu'il faut mettre en
oeuvre et cette capacité de dialogue et
de rassemblement je sais pour bien
connaître valérie pécresse que c'est au
coeur de sa façon de faire le programme
est sur l'éducation sera dévoilé au
cours de cette campagne à quelques
mesures déjà qu'ils sont sortis
notamment le fait qu'on puisse passer un
examen niveau à la fin de l'élémentaire
comme pour que les enfants ne soient pas
envoyés dans le collège unique comme ça
sans savoir lire écrire compter un jeu
les chiffres sont dramatiques on a de
moins en moins d'enfants qui savent lire
écrire compter à la sortie du primaire
et donc pouvoir aller vers une
sixième de consolidation qui permettrait
d'avoir un véritable sas pour rattraper
le retard de la même manière qu'il faut
effectivement plus d'heures de sur les
fondamentaux le français les
mathématiques sur les salaires parce que
j'invite la régie mm montrer ces
chiffres à regarder la france et tout
augmente derrière
sur les chiffres de de l'oscd eu un
bon dernière sur les sur les salaires
que fait valérie pécresse en ce sens on
sait que anne hidalgo voudrait doubler
les salaires on va vous poser la
question maxence
eu près de cent cinquante mille postes
de fonctionnaires donc pour l'éducation
nationale c'est quand même pas
incroyable alors revoyez vos fiches
puisque valérie pécresse a été très
clair sur le fait que pour se dégager
des marges de manoeuvre il y aura un non
renouvellement d'un fonctionnaire sur
trois jusqu'à atteindre un chiffre de
200 milles et non pas deux cent
cinquante mille comme vous l'évoquez
pour refinancer et la création de 50
mille postes de fonctionnaires dans des
secteurs on en a absolument besoin la
justice évidemment l'éducation est
évidemment la sécurité la protection
pour revenir c'est toujours dommage
qu'elle ait jamais été aux affaires
phalaris pécresse kg des ministres
nicolas sarkozy parce qu'elle aurait pu
faire tant de choses incroyables les
bas-fonds s'est déjà renseigné vous
puisque quand elle était mise en scène
alors c'est ainsi qu'elle en a fait
énormément des choses et la remercie la
meilleure cité elle n'a rien foutu et je
le savais très bien c'est donald
aujourd'hui c'est de la mesure est
peut-être passé c'est l'usure est et les
mesures que vous avez cités c'est celle
que j'étais chez moi je me suis pas
permis de vous un terreau mais surtout
on sert des personnes internes à des
personnels la d'éducation nationale qui
sont face à nous et je crois qu'on leur
doit beaucoup plus que des chicaneries
sur un plateau télé on doit se poser les
bonnes questions moi je n'imagine pas
être élu dans un pays où les professeurs
démissionne ou les médecins démissionne
ou toutes les personnes qui sont au
coeur des services publics qui font la
fierté d'un grand pays comme la france
revienne à détester leur travail qui
pour bien qu'ils ont choisi son passé
des concours pour le faire donc le but
n'est pas de dire on va traiter
absolument tous les professeurs de la
même manière et augmenté de 30 % tel ou
tel c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est
comment sur le terrain on fait en sorte
que les professeurs demain
s'épanouissent comment ont recréé en
valorisent cette fonction d'enseignant
en redonnant un cadre travaillant une
légitimité travail et évidemment les
moyens de travailler et ce ne sera pas
une fonction attractif demain sicile et
les professeurs ou les candidats à la
fonction professeurs se disent c'est pas
assez payés donc il ya évidemment à
remettre tout ça sur sur la table mais
je pense qu'il faut faire de manière
pragmatique dans un dialogue avec les
représentations on va les retrouver un
professeur fabrice frattini mais avant
justement sur cet état des professeurs
est amoral regarder ce sondage édifiant
76% et qui estiment avoir des troubles
du sommeil 27 % qui estiment leur métier
épuisant 51% qui déclarent avoir déjà eu
recours à un arrêt de travail fabrice
frattini là je vais me faire
volontairement provocatrice parce que ce
sont des questions qui peuvent voilà ici
ou là se poser quand qu'on ne connaît
pas votre métier on se dit bah voilà les
professeurs ont beaucoup plus de
vacances que des cadres du privé ou tout
simplement des salariés du privé
comment vous expliquer ces chiffres
terribles sur sur l'état des troupes si
j'ose dire sur l'état de moral des
troupes
une chose est déjà sûre qu'ils
travaillent
toujours temps de travail devant élèves
et l'autre travail c'est comme pour vous
en tant que journaliste vous faites une
émission d'une heure ne travaille pas
une heure par journée nous faisons une
nous sommes des 4 as de la fonction
publique nous avons un bac + 5 nous
avons un travail qui est intellectuelle
donc oui nous avons besoin du temps en
dehors de en dehors des salles de classe
et c'est un temps qui est très précieux
1 par rapport à ce qu'on va enseigner
ensuite repris d'un auprès de nos élèves
et justement il ya une charge de travail
qui augmente les charges de travail qui
de plus en plus complexes de plus avec
de plus en plus de tâches et bien sûr il
y a aussi
des raisons administratives des raisons
aussi politique des changements de
programme sans 1
507 les programmes changent également
des niveaux de vie au niveau des de ces
programmes qui sont deux des réformes
qui prend de plus en plus à l'opposé du
sens que nous faisons du métier il ya
qu'à voir la réforme par consupe la
réforme du bac juste pour vous dire par
exemple l'élève de terminale ont leur
bac dans six semaines alors que nous
sommes en pleine pandémie comment je
veux j'enseigne d'éternel comment est ce
que moi je peux me regarder dans un
miroir et me dire je vais réussir les
prépare au bac il ya eu deux libres et
dernière confie manquant lorsqu'il était
en seconde il ya une anxiété qui est
terrible par rapport à ça les élèves
sont anxieux comment est ce que moi je
peux me dire je fais bien mon métier je
fais du bachotage pendant six mois et
derrière je fais quoi derrière ma
matière j'enseigne quoi et ça ce n'est
qu'un exemple que l'exemple avec les
terminales pareil avec cette réforme du
bac ou dès la classe de seconde il
faudrait déjà que les élèves choisis des
spécialités qui vont les enfermer qui
vont devoir fermer des portes avec la
violence de parcours sud derrière donc
bien sûr votre métier perd de son sens
là maintenant à clé à nouveau que les
terminales ne sont en même temps
certificateur et pédagogue on doit
mettre des notes qui compte pour le bac
dont bien sûr nous perdons tous nos
repères en tant que pédagogue et et
c'est une charge mentale qui était co
qui est compliqué oui il ya des
collègues je suis représentant syndical
où il ya des collègues qui dort très mal
nous avons tous - moi y compris depuis
cette crise du pôle vite depuis toutes
ces réformes nous avons des problèmes de
sommeil c'est évident au cadastre oui
bien nicolas glières vous vous partagez
ce diagnostic que de fabrice frattini
parce que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
est parti sur cette mobilisation contre
ces protocoles
voilà la base des protocoles mais là on
va au delà la situation s'est vraiment
empiré dans dans le fonds même dans le
fondement de votre métier vous êtes
d'accord
complètement on a une charge de travail
qui a fait qui a passé son temps à
augmenter depuis les années 80 sans
salaire je dérape et tout à l'heure sont
la moindre contrepartie on fait plus
d'heures de cours qu'avant dans le sens
où on a plus de copier parce que plus
d'élèves les classes sont plus chargées
on nous a rajouté des tâches on a des
réunions gratuites non rémunéré je
connais pas un boulot où ça il y eu des
réunions selon l'humeur selon l'envi le
délire du chef d'établissement qui peut
décider de nous réunir sous menace de ne
pas nommer notre journée de travail
parce qu'on n'est pas venu à une réunion
une heure la énième dans une période
donnée les conseils de classe dur de
plus en plus longtemps des réunions
parents proches sont de plus en plus
courante régulière est longue sans un
centime
toutes ces choses là ne sont pas
rémunérés donc on est épuisé on se sent
déconsidérer y compris par la population
je dire il ya aussi une apathie
politique si vous voulez qu'ils doivent
un petit peu réfléchir par rapport à
notre métier mais aussi la population
générale les parents compris fermé mais
pourquoi nous méprisent style pourquoi
sont ils dans cette attitude
consumériste par rapport à l'école nous
sommes là pour transmettre des
connaissances à leurs enfants nous ne
sommes pas des ennemis ou ne doit pas
réglé ses comptes par rapport à l'école
qu'on a connu avec nous
les parents doivent être respectueux le
gouvernement doit être respectueux quels
qu'ils soient quelle que soit sa couleur
politique et nous n'avons pas su
ressenti là sur le terrain nous avons
des reproches des critiques on a 100 %
des parents qui sont devenus proches on
sait pas par quel miracle qu'ils sachent
comment faire court qui sert nous
expliquer comment faire court on a un
gouvernement qui nous change de
programme sans arrêt comme mon collègue
l'a très bien dit nous ça fait très
longtemps chez les ch'ti au rouge
contenant d'une enquête pour conflit
d'intérêt au niveau de l'éducation
nationale savoir qui parmi les membres
de l'éducation nationale dont les hauts
fonctionnaires ont des copains de la
famille desmarais ou des fans dans les
maisons d'édition on veut le savoir on
veut une enquête indépendante la france
est-elle une république bananière oui ou
non si c'est le cas on l'espère sinon on
fait quelque chose merci en tout cas à
tous les deux à fabrice frattini nicolas
glières pour votre témoignage merci à
vous deux mecs ans briquet vincent
genvrin sur ce plateau et d'avoir
accepté donc ce débat merci et au sénat
donc aucun accord n'a été trouvé entre
députés et sénateurs sur le pass
vaccinale après des négociations
concernant les modifications apportées
au texte par le sénat députés et donc
sénateurs ne se sont pas mis d'accord
les quatre modifications
une clause d'extinction pour que le
laissez-passer de soignies maintenu ni
imposer plus que nécessaire la
vérification d'identité supprimés dans
les bars et restaurants suppression des
sanctions également ministre hâtives en
cas de non respect du télétravail
exclusion des mineurs de cette
obligation c'est donc cette navette
parlementaire qui reprend le relais à
noter également que l'arrêté préfectoral
rendant obligatoire le masque en
extérieur à paris a été suspendue
et pour lutter contre la pandémie le
maire de nice propose lui aujourd'hui de
supprimer l'assurance chômage pour les
non vaccinés une idée donc de christian
estrosi qui indignent ses adversaires
politiques opposés au pass vaccinale
ciblé le porte-monnaie pour inciter à la
vaccination le québec l'envisagent en
tout cas lui sérieusement ce qui refuse
la moindre dose seront bientôt taxer les
explications de bilal à oiseaux ni avec
julia
dont sa lutte contre le coc u19 le
québec s'apprête à passer un nouveau cap
la province canadienne fortement touchée
par la vague omicron souhaite mettre en
place dans les prochaines semaines une
taxe pour toutes les personnes non
vaccinées
et de qui
le vaccin est la clé pour combattre le
virus c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons une
contribution santé pour les adultes qui
refusent de se faire vacciner pour des
raisons non médicales
les décors riches
ceux qui refuseront de recevoir leur
première 12 dans les semaines à venir
devront faire l'objet d'une nouvelle
contribution santé je sais que cette
situation est difficile mais nous
pouvons la traversée ensemble
pour l'heure aucun montant n'a été fixé
mais il sera significatif a tenu à
rappeler le premier ministre québécois
qui a qualifiée de fardeau pour le
système de santé les non vaccinés qui
représentent aujourd'hui 10% des
habitants de la province mais surtout
50% des personnes en soins intensifs
un choix dicté par la situation
difficile que vivent les hôpitaux en
manque de personnel les services de
santé sont saturées ce mercredi en
dénombrait 2000 742 personnes
hospitalisées à cause du coc vide et 255
en soins intensifs
le québec est l'un des premiers endroits
au monde à envisager ce genre de
taxation
si les personnes ne pouvant être
vaccinées pour des raisons médicales ne
seront pas impactés la mesure passe mal
du côté de l'opposition qui estime que
cette taxe n'est qu'un outil de plus
pour diviser les québécois
il ya quelques jours le québec avait
annoncé que certains commerces non
essentiels allait être interdit aux non
vaccinés en clients cette taxe il vient
de passer à la vitesse supérieure dans
sa lutte contre le virus
la sphère novak djokovic poursuit à
melbourne le numéro un mondial de tennis
est toujours dans la tente de savoir
s'il disputera oui ou non l'open
d'australie lundi prochain le serbe
novak signer a été autorisé à rester sur
le territoire australien après des
irrégularités concernant l'adoption d'un
visa ces derniers jours novak djokovic
s'est longuement défendu sur les réseaux
sociaux au sujet de ses différents tests
positifs ces dernières semaines ou
encore sur ses déplacements extra
sportifs que ministre australien de
l'immigration doit prendre la décision
finale alors que le premier ministre se
montre lui toujours intransigeant
écouter
tout ce que je dirai simplement c'est
que la raison que nous avions depuis le
15 décembre où les détenteurs de visas
éligibles entièrement vacciner pouvait
voyager en australie sans avoir besoin
de demander une exemption de voyage et
pour entrer dans les états qu'il est
autorisé à entrer sans quarantaine cette
personne doit montrer qu'elle est
doublement vaccinés ou doit fournir une
probable septembre qu'elle ne peut pas
être vaccinés pour des raisons médicales
telle est la politique en vigueur cette
politique n'a pas changé c'est la
politique est bien en temps nous
attendons des autorités qu'elle met en
oeuvre la politique du gouvernement sur
ces questions
et à l'instar de novak djokovic une
petite poignée de sportifs
professionnels refusent encore le vexin
à peine 5 % moyenne des réfractaires à
la piqûre n'ont pas nécessairement
nicvax mais plutôt effrayés par des
effets néfastes sur leur corps qui est
pour ainsi dire leur outil de travail
pour en parler nous sommes avec marine
partaud joueuse de tennis
professionnelle que cette 18e françaises
et 380 10e mondial bonsoir marine
partaud merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
alors on fait tout à fait transparent
vous nous y avait autorisé vous êtes
vacciné vous n'êtes pas spécialement
contre cette vaccination tout comme
d'ailleurs novak djokovic vous avez pu
vous même le covin malgré votre prudence
ce soir le numéro un mondial de tennis
est toujours sous la menace d'une
expulsion c'est une affaire politique
trop médiatisé quel est votre sentiment
de sportive
mais c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
parce que voilà nous on voyage
énormément
provac soin anti vaccin va pas débattre
sur le sujet après nous on est on est
obligé de 7,1 maxime vis-à-vis des
voyages là moi je suis actuellement aux
etats-unis et si jamais j'étais pas
vacciné je n'aurais pas pu venir ici
donc voilà après c'est vrai que
l'australie a mis en place une politique
extrêmement strictes et ce que je
comprends parce que voilà ça a été
l'état où ils ont été plus confiné
l'année dernière donc voilà je comprends
que les habitants il ya un petit peu de
frustration de leur part est d'avoir un
passe droit pour novak djokovic
oui et non parce que ben voilà il est nu
rang mondial d'accord mais moi je
connais une joueuse qui a été renvoyée
chez elle elle était simplement dans le
tableau double est exactement dans la
même situation que djokovic est l on en
n'a pas du tout parlé donc derrière tout
ça je pense qu'il ya un souci aussi des
kits et voilà c'est ça devient
près politique est effectivement au
niveau des gouvernements entre eux pour
une histoire comme comme novak djokovic
alors je ne sais pas s'il va pouvoir
jouer l'open d'australie mais c'est vrai
que tout ça prend une ampleur médiatique
assez énorme et c'est vrai qu'il peut
comme ce genre de situation et y avoir
voix là des choses peut-être qu'ils un
terrain je n'aurais djokovic qui dit
comme vous d'ailleurs vous avez hugo
vide lui aussi dit il je vais donc pas
me faire vacciner même si voilà il ya
des doutes en tout cas selon les
autorités australiennes sur se passe la
date de ce passe mais ça veut dire qu'on
doit se faire vacciner ayant eu le coc
vide ça n'a pas été simple imagine pour
vous prendre cette décision est
également
oui tout à fait et surtout que bon à la
base j'étais pas non plus une province
voilà j'avais plutôt envie qui est un
petit peu plus de recul sur sur tous
âges estimé que voilà c'est les tests
expérimentaux n'avait pas été fait dans
les temps impartis donkova je n'étais
pas forcément pour le vaccin mais encore
une fois j'ai pas forcément une fois
vis-à-vis de des tournois des
déplacements alors après ce qui est un
petit peu contradictoire c'est que on
arrive quand même sur les tournois même
en étant doublement de vacciner on a
quand même des tests pcr a montré à
l'arrivée on a du test pcr durant les
tournois après les tournois pour pouvoir
voyager à nouveau donc c'est vrai que
voilà on est doublement maxime et tout
toutefois on doit quand même présenter
des tests pcr et oui moi j'ai ressenti
effectivement les effets après le vaccin
puisque d'après le kof vide ou après le
vaccin lui-même voilà pendant pendant
plusieurs semaines j'ai eu du mal à
l'entraînement j'ai des difficultés
respiratoires plus que puisque
d'habitude donc je comprends certains
athlètes qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
vraiment réticents dont novak djokovic
parce que oui ça impacte
notre corps et nous effectivement en
étant sportif de haut niveau c'est notre
outil de travail au quotidien c'est vrai
que voilà par définition un athlète
n'est pas le commun des mortels dans son
rapport avec son corps ça c'est quelque
chose qui pour vous n'a pas été
adapté par les lois alors on va parler
de la france puisque nous sommes en
france il y a une spécificité tout de
même vous le dites c'est votre outil de
travail le régime n'est pas du tout le
même et on sent peut-être voilà certains
peut-être effet ça n'a pas les mêmes
conséquences pour vous comme pour
quelqu'un d'autre peut-être
oui oui tout à fait je me suis bien
renseigné auprès de mon médecin voilà
après avoir eu ma première ma deuxième
injection savoir quelles étaient les
préconisations à prendre en tant que
sportif de haut niveau parce
qu'effectivement on pousse notre corps à
l'extrême sans cesse donc voilà ça va
pas être un footing du dimanche entre
guillemets qu'on va aller faire si on
doit aller s'entraîner ça va être cinq
heures par jour donc si notre corps est
déjà affaibli par un virus ou par par le
vaccin qu'il est en train de lutter
contre quelque chose on le sait très
bien dans un état normal ou où on est
malade etc on va pas forcer sur notre
corps bas nous ça va être
soit 10 entre guillemets donc nous ne
serait qu il faut vraiment vigilant est
ce qu'il ya une vigilance at importante
de la part des autorités vis-à-vis des
sportifs de haut niveau concernant le
vaccin je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
nous et moi en tout cas personnellement
je sais que ça m'affecte voilà j'ai eu
ma deuxième dose courant décembre et
j'ai eu comme on recommence juste à
récupérer mes capacités respiratoires
sur le court aérobic en fitness etc donc
donc c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui on imagine que vous vous
échangé entre athlètes il ya d'ailleurs
les jeux olympiques de pékin qui
s'annonce
il ya une inquiétude or en ces temps de
pandémie pour les athètes parce qu'on
parle du vaccin mais enfin on parle
évidemment aussi lui du coup vite parce
que attraper le coc vite pour un athlète
on imagine qu'il peut y avoir là encore
des conséquences assez désastreuse et y
compris à long terme peut-être parfois
tout à fait moi quand j'ai attrapé le
coc vide pendant deux mois j'étais out
je pouvais pas m'entraîner enfin j'ai
essayé de m'entraîner mais vraiment sur
le terrain j'étais complètement fatigué
après je suis parti en tournoi mais
voilà ça a été très compliqué aussi
mais surtout nous entre guillemets en
tant que sport individuel où voilà moi
si je si je joue pas tournoi si je gêne
et aucune rentrée d'argent donc un
moment donné si ça nous pénalise pendant
deux mois voilà ça va être deux mois de
salaires qui vont être coupés et aucune
rentrée d'argent derrière ça donc c'est
vrai qu'il ya des conséquences
économiques aussi et qu'il faut pas
négliger et et au delà du fait que oui
ça nous atteint sur le plan
physiologique
il ya des réelles retombées économiques
derrière qui sont qui sont compliquées
pour les joueurs de second rang comme
moi évidemment comme novak djokovic a
n'a pas forcément l'impact et en termes
économiques mais il faut pas oublier
tous ceux qui sont derrière rossi et qui
sont aussi impactés par ce qu vide à la
même échelle que que les tout meilleurs
et on imagine en main on espère en tout
cas qu en 2024 les joueurs parient cette
pandémie sera bien derrière nous marine
pardo marque partout pardon merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et bonne chance à bout pour vos
prochaines compétitions merci à vous
fin du ballet diplomatique ce jeudi pour
désamorcer le risque d'un conflit en
ukraine après genève lundi et bruxelles
hier des diplomates russes et américains
et européens se sont réunis aujourd'hui
en autriche au siège de l'oif cee on en
parle tout de suite avec notre
correspondante à moscou maëlys d'estrées
bonsoir maylis les négociations qui
n'ont pas permis de débloquer la
situation la russie considère d'ailleurs
que les divergences sont sont trop
profondes
effectivement ce troisième round de
pourparlers n'a pas permis de sortir de
l'impasse la russie s'est dite déçue à
l'issue de la réunion de doha s'est elle
affirme en effet ne pas avoir reçu de
réponse claire aux propositions que la
soumise à l'occident pour garantir sa
sécurité moscow exige notamment que
l'otan ne s'élargisse pavin l'est une
extension à laquelle l'alliance
atlantique refuse de renoncer d'après le
représentant de la russie auprès de
l'ouest et cela fait longtemps que
l'organisation militaire n'est plus une
alliance défensive et que son extension
nuit à la sécurité en europe écoutez
l'accent est mis en particulier sur
l'attitude des états unis et de l'otan
qui commence est plutôt qu'ils
continuent à
leur conquête militaire de territoire de
pays qui sont entrés dans l'alliance
atlantique et à ils déployer des
systèmes d'armes qui
qui peuvent qui constitue une menace
directe pour les intérêts nationaux de
la fédération de russie nous ne pouvons
pas ne pas réagir et donc c'est un
moment historique et le président de la
fédération de russie a donc proposer des
schémas
qui suppose qu'on se mette d'accord sur
un nouveau système de sécurité dans
l'espace euro atlantique et d'entériner
ces garanties
et qui donc développe cette
notion de sécurité indivisible je tiens
d'ailleurs à préciser tout de suite
qu'une réponse
adaptée appropriée à notre proposition
n'a pas été communiqué nous n'avons rien
reçu en réponse est ni sur leurs
préoccupations et ni sur le prétendu
comportement agressif de la russie
notamment à la lumière des événements de
d'ukraine et ses alliés craignent en
effet une invasion de l'ukraine par
moscou en raison de mouvements de
troupes russes à la frontière russo
ukrainienne une intention fermement
démentie par le kremlin à plusieurs
reprises dans son discours
d'introduction la réunion de la bce le
président de l'organisation est revenu
sur ses sources de tensions écoutez
depuis plusieurs semaines nous sommes
confrontés à la possibilité d'une
escalade militaire majeure en europe de
l'est
les analystes militaire on signalait un
renforcement important des capacités
militaires dans la région
nous avons récemment entendu une demande
de garantie de sécurité
concernant une partie importante de la
zone de l'eau à eux et le discours
renouvelé sur les sphères d'influencé
tous ces aspects exige une évaluation
internationale sérieuse et une réaction
appropriée
compte tenu des divergences actuelles la
russie a d'ores et déjà fait savoir
qu'elle ne voyait pas de raison
d'organiser un nouveau round de
négociations dans les prochains jours
aussi bien les occidentaux que et russes
ont malgré tout souligné hier à
bruxelles l'importance qu'un dialogue
continue à exister entre eux mais rien
ne dit qu'il leur permettra de surmonter
les nombreux points d'achoppement de
leurs relations merci mais les eskers
pour ces informations en direct de
moscou
et place maintenant notre chronique
économique rendez vous incontournable du
jeudi la question qu'on se pose ce soir
et si la prochaine crise financière
venait de chine déjà épicentre
historique du coc vide la deuxième
économie mondiale doit maintenant gérer
la déconfiture de son secteur immobilier
avec la chute des leurs grandes ce
promoteur en défaut de paiement qui
croule sous une montagne dette après
avoir vu beaucoup trop grand alors pkr
est il en mesure de limiter la casse
l'immobilier chinois peut-il entraîner
une nouvelle crise comparable à celle
des subprimes on en parle tout de suite
avec l'économiste jacques sapir seller
dit aux échos
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques merci d'être avec nous
même à distance alors que se passe-t-il
aujourd'hui dans l'immobilier en chine
et bien stéphanie on est probablement en
présence des prémices d'une crise
financière majeure l'immobilier chinois
a donné naissance à des sociétés qui
sont devenus de véritables gérant et
parler des verts grande et bien sûr mais
il ya aussi d'autres comme fantasia ou
cynique ces sociétés sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement d'été elles sont confrontées
à la stabilisation voire à la baisse des
prix tant de la demande que de leur
secteur d'activité la situation s'est
donc dégradé depuis ces derniers mois et
il faut bien dire que les mesures qui
ont été prises par le gouvernement
chinois ont fait plus qu aggraver cette
situation
planté le décor qu'est-ce que hainard
grande alors eva granby a été créée en
1996 tout d'abord dans l'immobilier est
la vraie véritablement décoller à partir
des années 2000 quand le gouvernement
chinois a massivement soutenu le secteur
du logement le résultat était à
développement tout à fait astronomiques
la valeur de la société a été multiplié
par 8 de 2009 à 2010 est autrement dit
un taux de croissance de 30% par an
evergrande et a poursuivi une expansion
très agressive y compris dans des
entreprises qui sont très éloignées de
son secteur d'origine par exemple des
entreprises de véhicules électriques les
parcs à thèmes et bien d'autres secteurs
ainsi evergrande et a dépensé plus de 7
milliards de dollars entre 2019 et 2021
rien que dans le développement des
véhicules électriques alors ces
investissements comprennent aussi par
exemple le développement de l'ofen
flower island une un projet de
construction d'îles artificielles dans
la mer de chine et vers grande et est
donc devenu aujourd'hui un conglomérat
géant
à l'échelle chinoise alors vague
pourquoi les problèmes financiers
actuels avec ce que vous décrivez
alors l'endettement des verts grande et
stéphanie et des normes sont passives
autrement dit l'argent qu'elle doit aux
banques aux fonds d'investissement aux
autres sociétés immobilières et à des
particuliers dans le cadre d'une
politique de préachat des logements et
bien cet endettement atteint
actuellement 310 milliards de dollars
grosso modo 275 milliards d'euros
autrement dit 12% du pib de la france
ces empreintes avait été gagé sur le
portefeuille immobilier de l'entreprise
or depuis un an comme je les dis les
prix de l'immobilier ont cessé
d'augmenter certains ont même commencé à
baisser et donc la valeur immobilière du
capital qui sert de garantie à ses
empreintes se contracte les
investisseurs qui avaient prêté à river
grandet s'inquiète de plus il ya
maintenant des rumeurs de fraudes qui
circulent de manière insistante depuis
le mois d'octobre 2021 ces pratiques il
faut le dire ne se limite pas à evere
grandes elles sont courantes dans
plusieurs grandes sociétés immobilières
chinoises et on peut donc penser que et
20 grandes pourrait être un petit peu la
face émergée la partie émergée de
l'iceberg financiers en chine alors fait
que le gouvernement chinois est ce qu il
a pris la conscience quand même du
problème que vous nous décrivez oui
naturellement naturellement et dans un
effort pour freiner l'endettement
excessif du secteur immobilier le
gouvernement chinois a adopté une
stratégie dite des trois lignes rouges
en 2020 pour justement limiter les
volumes dans près alors ça veut dire que
les différentes sociétés doivent
respecter trois ratios un ratio entre
leurs niveaux de dette et les liquidités
immédiates qu'elles ont un ratio entre
les dettes et les fonds propres en
général un autre ratio entre les dettes
et les actifs ces réglementations il
faut bien le dire ont fortement impacté
evergrande --la société a annoncé en
mars 2021 qu'elle cherchait à réduire
son endettement de 23 milliards de
dollars 23 milliards de dollars par
rapport à 310 milliards de dollars on
voit c'est pas énorme malgré tout comme
réduction mais au moins il faut aussi
rappeler qu'evergrande était toujours en
expansion
l'année dernière elle avait lancé pas
moins de 63 projets dans le cours de
2021 alors d'autres réglementations ont
été prises que ce soit par le
gouvernement central ou par les
gouvernements locaux le résultat c'est
que en octobre 2021 quatorze des trente
plus grandes sociétés immobilières
chinoises se trouvait en infraction avec
au moins une des règles alors l'une
était en infraction avec les trois
règles que j'ai cités et villes grandes
et et greenland holding en avait
enfreint deux et les 11 autres sociétés
un vo en fera au moins une de ces
réglementations et on se demande
évidemment que peut faire pékin telle
est la marge de manoeuvre
oui effectivement alors plus il ya le
problème des risques que vous comprenez
bien le risque il est tout d'abord
direct un certain nombre de banques ou
de fonds d'investissement américains ou
européens on prêtait déjà de l'argent à
un grade et subirait évidemment les
conséquences d'une faillite de cette
société cependant le risque est aussi
peut-être même surtout un risque
indirect déjà des sociétés de taille
moyenne comme fantasia ou chimiques sont
en défaut de paiement mais avec
l'hypothétique faillite d'evergrande il
faudrait s'attendre à ce que de
nombreuses sociétés soit entraîné avec
elle car si le secteur de l'immobilier
s'effondre en chine et ce secteur il
faut toujours le rappeler représente
pratiquement 30% presqu'un tiers du pib
de la chine est bien la crise sera
profonde parce que ça touche aussi une
partie de l'industrie qui alimente ce
secteur est par ailleurs ces crises ne
fera pas que toucher la chine une forte
récession de l'économie chinoise
contaminera immédiatement les économies
occidentales celle des états de tissu
mais aussi celle de l'allemagne qui
exporte beaucoup par rapport à la chine
merci jacques sapir est resté avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
la présidentielle et de la gauche
toujours plus divisés hidalgo qui a vu
sa proposition de primaire de gauche
contesté et bien aujourd'hui la maire de
paris annoncé qu'elle irait jusqu'au
bout quoi qu'il en coûte ça ne l'a pas
dit mais c'est l'idée
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple c'était
une volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
pays il est clair que tout le monde
attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj jones étaient
des valeurs de droite c'était des gens
qui travaillent c'est les gens qui
avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l oblique
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il ya quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire ce soir la présidentielle 2022
anne hidalgo annonce aujourd'hui qu'elle
ira évidemment au bout après l'échec de
son idée de primaires à gauche et malgré
des sondages toujours inquiétant
pourtant elle a pris vers populaire aura
bien lieu pour tenter de réunir la
gauche fin janvier sans candidat écolo
yannick jadot qui n'y participera pas
tout comme les candidats de la france
sont mises ont luc mélenchon et du parti
communiste fabien roussel à moins de
trois mois du scrutin pour les voyants
sont au rouge alors la gauche qu'est ce
qui cloche est-ce que c'est du chacun
pour soi on attend vos réactions sur le
conte télégramme
à moins de trois mois donc du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle la
gauche arrivera t-elle enfin à s'unir
tous les signaux montrent bien au
contraire qu'on s'en éloigne de plus en
plus un flou qui accompagne de faibles
intentions de vote dans les sondages
nicolas fontaine
c'est un des jours les plus importants
de la campagne présidentielle d'anne
hidalgo
la maire de paris a présenté ce jeudi
son programme nommé libération une
feuille de route comprenant 70
propositions pour répondre aux urgences
sociales climatique et démocratique
sommes partis d'une question simple quel
avenir souhaitons nous pour nos enfants
quelle france voulons-nous je m'empresse
de vous dire certainement pas la france
des manuels macron la france est frappée
par trois crises
c'est aussi ce diagnostic qui est au
coeur des propositions
mon programme est un programme de gauche
écologistes socialistes sociale
démocrate ou encore social et
républicain
en grande difficulté dans les sondages
avec 2 à 5% d'intentions de vote la
candidate socialiste a vu sa proposition
de primaire de gauche contesté jean luc
mélenchon ou encore yannick jadot l'on
refusé à plusieurs reprises et son
initiative a même fini par semer le
trouble dans le camp socialiste le
candidat écologiste ne se voit également
pas participer à la primaire populaire
près du samedi prochain face à ce refus
la candidate du ps maintient l'idée dit
prends repart tout en se refusant à
abandonner la course à l'elysée en cas
de revers le leader de la france
insoumise jean luc mélenchon est
également en difficulté et peinent à
obtenir les 500 signatures de maires
nécessaires à sa candidature à la
présidentielle alors à laquelle je vous
parle j'approche les 400 signatures mais
ce n'est pas cinq sens et il ne me reste
que 50 jours cinquante quatre jours pour
parvenir à avoir des promesses qui
ensuite se traduirait en déclaration au
conseil constitutionnel dans le même
temps christiane taubira qui fait
toujours planer le doute sur sa
participation à l'élection d'avril
prochain devrait déclarer sa candidature
dans les prochains jours l'ex garde des
sceaux a par ailleurs annoncé qu'elle se
soumettrait aux résultats de la primaire
populaire
je proclame que j'accepte les règles de
la première populaire je prends et
j'accepte le risque de la démocratie
et surtout
j'accepterai le verdict de la première
populaire enfin arnaud montebourg
devrait très prochainement révélé la fin
de sa campagne présidentielle ayant
annoncé cette semaine l'échec de la
remonte à da sont partis politiques et
actant qu'ils n'obtiendraient pas les
500 signatures nécessaires à la course à
l'elysée on vous pensez vous que la
gauche peut garder l'espoir de se
rapprocher pour cette présidentielle
notre journaliste sébastien duffo or use
a posé la question écouter un nom pour
moi non il y aura pas d'entente pour moi
il y aura pas d'entente ils sont trop
égocentrique surhumain eux-mêmes donc il
peut pas voir autre chose que
le bout de leur nez je pense qu'ils sont
divisés et puis c'est tout quoi voilà
c'est de la division donc il n'ya pas
s'ils sont pas unis donc c'est de la
division c'est tout pour gagner voulu
dire dans quel pays pourront jamais
s'unir donc il n'y a pas d'eau à mon
avis non ils n'arriveront pas à trouver
un un compromis ce qui serait bénéfique
et on le veut tous mais pour moi c'est
rédhibitoire j'y crois pas je pense
qu'elle doit peut-être trouvé nouvelle
manière de punir je pense pour la
prochaine candidature celle ci je pense
qu'il ya aucune chance mais je pense
qu'à l'avenir une photo et moi y
retrouver un élan de gauche et remettre
le thème de gauche en avant - les thèmes
de droite alors anne hidalgo la
candidate ps qui veut se lancer dans la
course à l'élysée coûte que coûte malgré
les sondages toujours inquiétant la
primaire populaire qui aura bien lieu
pour tenter de réunir la gauche fin
janvier sans les candidats yannick jadot
les candidats jean luc mélenchon
également fabien roussel bref la gauche
chacun pour soi point d'interrogation on
attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme et c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau patrick le hyaric
éditorialiste à l'humanité bonsoir
patrick le hyaric merci d'être avec nous
nous accompagne également stéphane rozès
politologue président de cap m stéphane
rozès qui enseigne également à chausser
à sciences po vous allez également
stéphane rozès conseillers de zs ancien
candidat socialiste à la présidentielle
ségolène royal en 2007 et françois
hollande en 2012 vous connaissez donc
extrêmement bien ce sujet de de la
gauche parmi d'autres sujets que vous
maîtrisez merci d'être avec nous donc là
d'un chien on l'a vu réunis dans la rue
aujourd'hui
contre le protocole sanitaire de jean
michel blanquer r pas vraiment l'unir
dans les urnes vont nous faire réagir
messieurs je voudrais vous montrez ce
sondage le dernier en date est la bière
voici ce que ça donne jean luc mélenchon
5% yannick jadot
6,5 je vous laisse découvrir le reste
des sports hanoi delgo qui n'est même
pas quelle pour 135 nathalie arthaud en
queue de peloton 0,5 alors au tour
d'alain ça fait 23% des intentions de
vote pas moins de huit candidats en
dessous des 10% stéphane rozès votre
réaction votre analyse
ces chiffres m une gauche à 20 % il ya
dix ans un tiers des français se
retrouvait dans la gauche et les
difficultés de la gauche que vous avez
énoncés ne vient pas selon moi de sa
division celle inverse c'est parce que
la gauche c'est dans la dernière période
éloigné de ses fondamentaux la nation la
question sociale la république qu'elle
s'est peu à peu et millet t il divise et
quand la gauche est indexé sur le sujet
du pays et sur ses fondamentaux quelles
que soient les volontés des uns et des
autres des dynamiques majoritaire à
uniterre se met en place et bien là
celle inverse donc nous sommes
certainement à la fin d'un cycle avec
une tendance de chacune des sensibilités
de gauche a essayé de retrouver des
fondamentaux soient écologistes soient
des coûts va bien ussel
communiste ceux qui sont les plus en
difficulté
c'est plutôt la famille socialiste qui a
aussi aidé en la gagnant période entre
néolibéralisme et
communautarisme patrick le hyaric vous
êtes d'accord avec cette analyse un
petit peu dissonante 1 2 de stéphane
rozès entendez ces français nous y
revoilà il se plante tout simplement
parce que c'est chacun pour soi ouais et
chacun vit sa vie stéphane rozès m'ont
dit non c'est parce que tout simplement
la gauche s'éloigner de ses fondamentaux
vous partagez vous ce déclic oui je suis
assez proche de ce que dit stéphane
rozès
l'expérience du dernier quinquennat
laisse des traces extrêmement rude et le
fait que de ce dernier quinquennat vous
parlez de sa vie de france fort celui de
françois hollande donc le parce que
n'oublions pas que le parti socialiste a
eu la totalité des leviers pendant un
temps il a lui-même la présidence du
sénat la majorité des départements la
majorité des régions le le gouvernement
de majorité à l'assemblée nationale
donc qu'ils avaient les moyens de créer
les conditions pour affronter la
mondialisation capitaliste il ne l'a pas
fait il a accompagné et le fait que sort
de ce quinquennat l'ancien secrétaire
général adjoint de l'elysée ministre des
finances eh bien ça brouille est encore
plus les cartes et le nom le mot gauche
aujourd'hui pour un certain nombre de
gens ne veut pas dire ce que nous
souhaiterions c'est à dire le combat
pour la justice l'égalité
l'environnement et la démocratie 3 c'est
à dire que la gauche a finalement trahi
son électorat tout d'abord comme le dit
patrick le hyaric avec françois hollande
et avec emmanuel macron parce que c'est
vrai qu'on se souvient tout de même
qu'il était à gauche et dans un
gouvernement socialiste
je fais remonter le divorce un peu en
amont au fond comme la gauche et où
départ le parti socialiste semble
renoncer aux questions sociales pour
aller vers les questions sociétales
substitut la république d
d'assembler des minorités c'est la note
de la fondation
néolibérale terra nova
prétendants ou font faire converger des
minorités de nature ni ferrante et puis
je rajouterais 12 l'intérieur d'ailleurs
pour moi de la candidature de femme
yarmouth elle sait que pour fois la
gauche
semble-t-elle disparaître parce que la
situation est tellement grave
pour les français que le sud vienne
n'est plus seulement essentiellement
économiques et sociales mais c'est
l'idée de la france elle même et de son
modèle or ce bienvenue à gauche dans la
dernière période
elle ne parle plus de la france elle
parle des questions purement économique
et social mais qui sont inclus avait
dans notre histoire
dans l'agression nationale et je ne vois
pas que la gauche puisse revenir sans
poser la question de la souveraineté
et de la reprise de la france hugues de
sur la maîtrise de son destin elad dont
la gauche est bien être par l'économique
social écologie c'est pas ça soit pas
important mais c'est enclavé dans la
question rom hier qui est pour les
français la question nationale la
question de la souveraineté
la question de la maîtrise de notre
destin patrick le hyaric c'est un gros
mot pour la gauche la souveraineté c'est
l'apanage de de la droite qui s'en est
emparé et cevital est pas du tout la
notion de souveraineté populaire est une
notion de gauche est à dire la
possibilité pour les citoyens de décider
réellement quand on leur a dit vous avez
pu voter non contre le projet de
constitution européenne
mais quand même on l'appliquera c'est le
contraire du respect de la souveraineté
populaire dont ça a porté un coup
extrêmement dur
à la démocratie elle même et à la
croyance dans la souveraineté du et ça
c'était pas spécialement la gauche qui a
trahi effectivement dans les allusions à
ce référendum de 2005 il ya eu celle de
2005 ausy est arrivé au pouvoir après
n'a effectivement pas forcément raison 7
il a fait une majorité des
parlementaires socialistes
et d'ailleurs on se souvient qu'ils
avaient une fameuse une d'un grand
magazine que je ne citerai pas ici où il
y avait un ensemble président sarkozy et
le leader de l'opposition entre
guillemets de l'époque françois hollande
qui a appelé à la même chose c'est à
dire oui et donc à partir de ce moment
là la question de la souveraineté
populaire c'est-à-dire une partie de la
question que soulève stéphane rozès ll
évidemment elles à discréditer ce qu'on
appelle la gauche il faut ajouter à cela
c'est que il y a eu un accompagnement
quand même de la mondialisation
capitaliste
dès les années 80 trois cantons à
de créer les conditions pour favoriser
les bourses la liberté de circulation
des capitaux ce qu'on a appelé la
compétitivité c'est à dire la mise en
concurrence des travailleurs entre eux
qui permet les délocalisations à partir
de ce moment là on a fait très mal à
l'électorat de la gauche c'est à dire
alors au sens large à la classe ouvrière
c'est à dire aux classes travailleuses
et à l'intérieur de ceux-ci aujourd'hui
on est dans une autre phase il ya une
mutation on n'est plus tout à fait dans
la classe ouvrière regroupées dans deux
grandes entités et c'est dans le livre
par exemple de jérôme fourquet en voit
que
les travailleurs dans la logistique ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui une partie des
premières lignes des premiers de corvée
de vienne ont une place extrêmement
importante seulement ceux là sont isolés
ont des difficultés à se syndiquer en
difficulté à trouver du temps d'abord
pour militer dans des associations ou
est dans un parti politique de gauche
pourquoi candidats comme arnaud
montebourg quand on écoute vos deux
discours n'imprime pas davantage
stéphane rozès 10.5 aujourd'hui dans ce
dernier sondage d'arnaud montebourg qui
va probablement se retirer
on fonde vous avez raison de poser la
question ainsi arnaud montebourg a
déclaré denis roussel à gauche étaient
ceux qui portaient
l'attrition de la souveraineté
[Musique]
et puis ring seymour rapporté
l'agression la france au plan
identitaire et culturelle marine le pen
à sa façon pose c'est d'admission la
souveraineté mais cas ci s'est passé
avec arnaud montebourg
c'est que il a abordé la question de la
souveraineté sous l'ongle du patriotisme
économique sous l'ongle de
l'économie or selon moi
subjectivement ignoble chez activement
la le malheur français la crise
française
ne vient n'a pas comme origine un
dessaisissement d'abord de sa
souveraineté économique et social
il a d'abord une hausse
politique ça a été dit la nation
française pour préserver ces rapports
sociaux a besoin de se projeter dans
l'espace le temps une vision et le
sommet de l'état demande à la nation de
faire leur verse
d'intérioriser des disciplines économie
de l'union européenne mais ce processus
a comme fondement selon moi une raison
une cause non pas économique et social
mais d'abord politique donc le projet
d'arnaud montebourg était fort
intéressant sur le fond sauf qu'ils
étaient abordés toujours par l'économie
et ce n'est qu'après qu'il posait les
questions politiques de la france de la
république
il aurait fallu selon - flers linverse
on va regarder cette réaction télégramme
de pascal la gauche s'est trahi et
discréditer en faisant croire à ses
électeurs qu'elle avait des valeurs de
gauche là ils sont masqués patrick huard
x et on en revient à cette forme de
trahison c'est ce que ressentent
beaucoup d'électeurs de gauche
aujourd'hui mais trahison c'est à dire
on n'a pas créé le rapport de forces
pour affronter la mondialisation
capitaliste
elle a été accompagnée et le parti
socialiste et notamment qui était à
intégrer dans le parti socialiste
européen qui était déjà avant cela bien
plus à droite que le parti socialiste
français parce qu'il y avait un parti
communiste relativement fort
et bien s'est aligné sur ses dogmes en
quelque sorte est devenu avec elle le
choix et avait-elle la marge de
manoeuvre pour faire autrement oui parce
que on peut on peut en appeler au peuple
on peut même à un commissaire européen
dans le socialiste dans le collège des
commissaires il peut s'opposer un
certain nombre de choses au parlement
européen au lieu de faire des alliances
entre le groupe de droite et le groupe
social-démocrate on pouvait créer une
autre alliance écologiste gauche
unitaire et socialisme ce qui a été fait
parfois mais qui a montré qu'on pouvait
modifier un certain nombre de choses et
surtout s'appuyer sur les volontés
populaires c'est-à-dire sur les
mouvements sociaux que voulez vous quand
on a emmené les canons à eau contre les
infirmières ça nous dit quelque chose
aujourd'hui c'est quand même un ministre
socialiste qui a emmené les canons à eau
contre des infirmières qui manie fait
qu'ils manifestaient il ya de cela très
longtemps parce qu'il fallait rentrer
dans ses dogmes
européiste en quelque sorte c'est à dire
une europe
très libéral donc c'est toutes ces
questions là et dans le cas d'un
affaiblissement
de la force du parti communiste est un
parti socialiste qui se déportait de la
social démocratie authentique vers un
social-libéralisme parce que le
mot gauche à appliquer à tout le monde
aujourd'hui à toutes les forces
politiques induit un certain nombre de
confusion je crois séphane rozès anne
hidalgo 1 donc on n'en parlait a
confirmé qu'elle irait coûte que coûte
au bout de cette aventure ça fait une
participante d'ailleurs en moins à la
primaire populaire ça veut dire que que
c'est fini pour christiane taubira où
elle peut finalement transformé en une
candidature de gauche supplémentaire
il ya la question des parrainages
christiane taubira devrait emporter la
première populaire
bizarrement sur le fond arnaud
montebourg qui a peu à voir avec eux les
positions un peu
impressionniste ou poétiques de
christiane taubira
devrait se rallier mais de toute façon
il faut les les parrainages donc je
crois que beaucoup se disent la
présidentielle s'est perdu et à dalou
requis sur toutes ces questions a
énormément varié finalement sous la
pression du parti
socialiste ils se disent bon c'est foutu
la présidentielle mais autant
conserver ce que nous sommes pour la
près
donc
la position et effectivement
pour d'algos de courir sous ses propres
couleurs au risque d'un score
cataclysmique et faisant que le ps se
réduisent à un des fiefs beaucoup autour
de quelques aux métropoles et région
ségolène royal a d'ailleurs réagi
aujourd'hui elle dit la gauche en
substance est la seule responsable de
cette situation les diviser chaotique
elle n'a pas su organiser de primaires
n'a pas su travailler avec ses
partenaires cette question patrick lui
eric de primaire ça aurait pu quand même
sauvé un petit peu un petit peu les
choses au moins pour apporter un
discours lisible des propositions d'ici
pour le l'idée
l'idée sympathique que lille ne faut pas
la rejeter d'emblée ceci dit une
primaire pour quoi faire et sur quels
objectifs parce que le problème il est
là le problème c'est que quand madame
hidalgo
elle dit qu'elle veut revenir à la
social démocratie et la semaine suivante
elle va à tu
et se déplace au marché de tulle avec
françois hollande elle ne donne pas le
signal qui revient à la
social-démocratie ce que j'appelle la
social démocratie authentique parce que
françois hollande n'a pas un quart des
la social démocratie il a incarné un
social-libéralisme très libérale
d'ailleurs quelques fois il n'y avait
pas toujours du social est
donc une des questions qui est posée
aujourd'hui
pour nous tous pour les médias pour les
responsables publics etc c'est de
réfléchir c'est à dire que on a des
portes et où le débat à droite depuis
des mois et des mois
rendez vous compte que la primaire de
droite à 2 a fait l'objet de quatre
débats télévisés dont un débat sur la
télévision publique
pendant ce temps là la gauche a été
étouffée est aujourd'hui la seule
campagne à propos de la gauche c'est de
dire il faut qu'ils aillent à une
primaire populaire mais ceci ne fait pas
dans tout état de cause ne ferait pas
gagné strictement une voix la question
qui est posée c'est de laisser les
forces politiques de gauche exposé
d'ailleurs moi j'aurais été content on a
été très heureux si tous les candidats
de gauche et même toutes les forces
politiques de gauche puissent bénéficier
aussi de son primaire des débats
politiques entre eux devant les citoyens
de telle sorte que les citoyens se
fassent leurs opinions et d'ailleurs sur
les plateaux de télévision bas il peut
se faire on voit les dissonances on voit
les divergences on voit aussi les points
d'accord mais menez campagne uniquement
aujourd'hui sur cette question la
primaire populaire
empêche parce que ça crée de l'illusion
empêche l'électorat de gauche de se
mobiliser et cris des conditions pour
augmenter l'abstention du côté gauche
voire pour empêcher la droite et
l'extrême droite à refaire voter macron
même s'ils ne sont pas d'accord avec
monsieur macron merci beaucoup à tous
les deux patries cagliari stéphane rozès
d'avoir été avec nous pour nous apporter
votre analyse sur cette gauche qui est
décidément bien en en difficulté à trois
mois de l'élection présidentielle et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi dès
20h pour un nouveau numéro d'ici là
n'oubliez pas de réagir de commenter ou
de poser vos questions sur le télégramme
d'ayrté france
d
[Musique]
olivier maintenant détenu depuis huit
mois quelles sont les nouvelles pas les
nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement ils sont coupés de tout
il n'est pas dans un hôtel capturé avec
un téléphone et il peut me donner des
nouvelles non à votre avis quelles sont
ses conditions de détention aujourd'hui
c'est sûr elles sont très difficiles
parce que les anciens otages ont pu nous
le raconter qu'il a des conditions de
vie qui sont très rudimentaires et très
dur j'espère vraiment de tout mon coeur
qui qui reçoit notre énergie moi
j'essaye de faire de mon mieux tout
simplement pour qu'ils m'entendent parce
que c'est ça mon travail c'est la france
et le mali où là